righty now I almost approached it like
exercise I get up maybe at 4:30 the
morning takes an hour to get going and
then I'll start to write about maybe 3
hours and then it becomes repetitive and
the next day I get up and even if I
don't feel inspired I'll sit there first
three hours until I get the brain says
ok you must start to produce something
so I try to write quickly and I and I
follow a pattern just the way you would
be if you were in the Army or whatever
and then that gets me through it quickly
some writers will take a year to you
everyone has a different process but
that's what I do I write better in the
morning
like my mother sorry right I use I used
to write at night all the time when I
was but I found that everything everyone
died it was dark and creepy there was a
really horrible is like very depressing
then I realized Edgar Allan Poe used to
write at night now I figure out what you
have to try I have to see if you really
are what you think you are and by that I
mean I wanted one chance to prove
whether I was a good actor allows the
actor or whether I should go get a Dairy
Queen stand if employment all real
should get out of acting and I just
needed one vehicle the further I had to
be up there just just enough to say
Jesus he stinks along you just watched
two amazing clips from Sylvester
Stallone take the next three minutes and
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]